ich rufe auf den tagesordnungspunkt 3
bekanntgabe der bildung der
bundesregierung
der herr bundespräsident hat mir hierzu
mit schreiben vom heutigen tage
mitgeteilt gemäß artikel 64 absatz 1 des
grundgesetzes für die bundesrepublik
deutschland habe ich heute auf vorschlag
der frau bundeskanzlerin ernannt
sigmar gabriel zum bundesminister für
wirtschaft und energie dr frank walter
steinmeier zum bundesminister des
auswärtigen dr thomas de maizière zum
bundesminister des innern heiko maas zum
bundesminister der justiz und für
verbraucherschutz dr wolfgang schäuble
zum bundesminister der finanzen
andrea nahles zur bundesministerin für
arbeit und soziales dr hans peter
friedrich zum bundesminister für
ernährung und landwirtschaft
dr ursula von der leyen zur
bundesministerin der verteidigung
manuela schwesig zur bundesministerin
für familie senioren frauen und jugend
hermann gröhe zum bundesminister für
gesundheit
alexander dobrindt zum bundesminister
für verkehr und digitale infrastruktur
dr barbara hendricks zur
bundesministerin für umwelt naturschutz
und reaktorsicherheit dr johanna wanka
zur bundesministerin für bildung und
forschung dr gerd müller zum
bundesminister für wirtschaftliche
zusammenarbeit und entwicklung sowie
peter altmaier zum bundesminister für
besondere aufgaben
und nun entfaltet sich eben doch die
spekulation was das im einzelnen wohl
alles bedeuten könne
ich rufe nun auf den tagesordnungspunkt
4 eidesleistung der bundesminister meine
damen und herren nach artikel 64 absatz
2 des grundgesetzes leisten die
bundesministerin und bundesminister bei
der amtsübernahme vor dem deutschen
bundestag den in artikel 56 des
grundgesetzes vorgesehene neid ich werde
den eid vorsprechen und bitte dann die
mitglieder der bundesregierung den eid
mit den worten ich schwöre es so wahr
mir gott helfe oder ich schwöre es zu
bekräftigen
ich darf vielleicht zunächst den
bundesminister sigmar gabriel zu mir
bitten und spreche zunächst den eid vor
und bittet das dann mit den eidesformel
zu bekräftigen
ich schwöre dass ich meine kraft dem
wohle des deutschen volkes widmen seinen
nutzen mehren schaden von ihm wenden das
grundgesetz und die gesetze des bundes
wahren und verteidigen meine pflichten
gewissenhaft erfüllen und gerechtigkeit
gegen jedermann üben werde
herr präsident ich schwöre es so wahr
mir gott helfe
herzlichen glückwunsch
herr bundesminister dr steinmeier
wir tragen den jetzt nicht jedes mal
herr bundespräsident ich schwöre es so
wahr mir gott helfe herzlich
herr minister dr de maizière
bundestagspräsident ich schwöre es so
wahr mir gott helfe herzlichen bekannt
jetzt kommt erst der bundesminister für
justiz und verbraucherschutz heiko maas
inter-präsident ich schwöre es so wahr
mir gott helfe
herr minister dr schäuble
präsident ich schwöre es so wahr mir
gott helfe
frau bundesministerin nahles herr
präsident ich schwöre es so wahr mir
gott helfe
herr bundesminister niedrig die schwöre
es so wahr mir gott helfe
frau bundesministerin von der leyen
herr präsident ich schwöre es so wahr
mir gott helfe
frau bundesministerin schwesig herr
präsident ich schwöre es so wahr mir
gott helfe
der bundesminister grün herr präsident
ich schwöre es so wahr mir gott helfe
herr bundesminister dobrindt
frau bundesminister dr hendrix herr
präsident ich schwöre es so wahr mir
gott helfe
vor bundesministerin dr danke herr
präsident ich schwöre es so wahr mir
gott helfe
herr bundesminister dr
herr präsident ich schwöre es so wahr
mir gott helfe
herr bundesminister altmaier herr
präsident ich schwöre es so wahr mir
gott helfe mit besonders
meine damen und herren liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen die mitglieder der
bundesregierung haben den nach artikel
64 absatz 2 des grundgesetzes
vorgeschriebene neid vor dem deutschen
bundestag geleistet ich spreche den
mitgliedern der bundesregierung noch
einmal persönlich aber auch im namen des
hauses die besten wünsche für die
übernommenen aufgaben aus wir sind damit
am schluss unserer heutigen tagesordnung
ich beruf für die nächste sitzung des
bundestages ein auf morgen mittwoch den
dezember um 9 uhr die sitzung ist
geschlossen